カップ焼きそば代表格の一角、ペヤング焼きそば
あ、もう、思い出したくないです。
激辛ペヤング焼きそば
健康志向?!悪くないね！鉄分MAXペヤング焼きそば
な、なぜだ！なぜワカメを入れた？ペヤング焼きそばわかめMAX醤油味
洋風だと！悪くはない。だが、もはや焼きそばでも無い気が(
ペペロンチーノ風ペヤング焼きそば
美味しいものを食べるには代償を伴う。
周りの人を傷つける覚悟があるか。
ペヤング焼きそばにんにくMAX
割といけそうな気がしてしまう。
ペヤング焼きそばプラス納豆
ごめん。漢字が読めない（酸辣「すーらー」だよ！）
パクチーって、そもそもなんだっけ？
ペヤング焼きそばパクチーマックス
なぜ作った？ペヤング焼きそばチョコレート
何回かペヤングを混ぜる動画を出したことがあるんですよ。
その頃はまだね多分ここらへんしかなかった。
ここら辺プラス何かあったぐらいの
まだ、少なかった頃。
気づいた時にはもう遅かった！
気づいた。
お前は～
ははあああ～
お前は～！
はい、というわけで、
ペヤング焼きそば。
あの～
すっげーいろんな味が出てませんか？
もうびっくりするくらい！
びっくりするくらいいろんな味が出てました。
僕はずっと黙ってましたよ！
僕はずっと黙ってたんですけど、
まあなんだろ、ここら辺とか
イカ墨ペヤングあたりはー
まあーなんかこう、うんうんまあまあまあ、ってかんじだったんですけども。
ちょっとここ最近すごいいろんなのがでてるな
もうここら辺からちょっと怪しいとは思ったよ。
チョコレート味が出た瞬間からちょっと路線が変わってきたなと思いつつ、
前から面白いのはあったんですけども、
最近めちゃくちゃ多いなと思ってちょっと
ここ最近のペヤング焼きそばをちょっと集めてみました。
まあ要するに、ペヤングさんも何を求めてるかというと、
美味しい焼きそばを求めて、
いろんな味を作る。
すなわち！
要するに「美味しい焼きそば作ろう」「美味しい焼きそば作ろう」って、
こうやってみんな頑張っている訳ですよ。
ていうことは、この美味しい焼きそば同士を混ぜ合わせると、
1番美味しい焼きそばに辿りつけるんじゃねーかと思いまして、
ほらだって、ほら。
そして美味しい焼きそば
もういろんな要素が混じるんですよ！
いろんな要素が混じれば多分、最高に美味しい焼きそばができると思ってる！俺は！
もう、言いたいことはわかるとは思うが、
俺は、今日、
最高に美味しい焼きそばを作る。
悪いな、みんな。
この味を
俺はこの味をみんなに伝えることはできないが
せめてもの！映像記録として、ここに、残しておく。
ではいこう！！
とりあえず、開けていきます！
はい、というわけで。
うわあ～
ここから、全部お湯を入れて、3分待ってあっためます。
GO！！
っしゃオラ！
っしゃあ！まずぺぺ！！
オラァ
っしゃあ～。できたー！
じゃあ入れていきます！
あああーっつ！！
オッケー！
はい、というわけで、全部入れたんですけど、
なんでこうねぇ～
ピョンピョンピョンピョンなりますかねぇ
(ピョン！ピョン！)
まてやって
オイ！
(バン！)
3分間待って、お湯を捨てるとこまでやっていきます
はい、というわけで、全部の湯切りが終わりました
そこでちょっと作っていきましょう
まずはノーマル
ノーマルじゃないぞたぶん
なんか臭いぞこれ
あーこれたぶんパクチーだな
おうおうおうおう
ソーッ！スがッ！
うわやちゃった 、やばいやったやったやった
えええー！
わかめMAXってこのレベルなの？！
うわ、わかめ超うまそうだな
あああー！
貴様もかー！
うわうわうわ
うわ！納豆臭っ
うわこれ納豆じゃん
はい、というわけで、ひと通り完成しました
はい、というわけで、まずはちょっと軽く味見していきましょう
まずはパクチー
ああ～
ペペロンチーノ
うまい！
たぶんノーマル
サイコー！！
わかめ
んんんー、うんうんうん、うまいうまいうまい
じゃあ次にんにくMAX
うん
次鉄分MAX
うまい！
漢字の酸っぱいやつ（すーらー）
ンフッ
えほえほっ
すっぱ
激辛ペヤング
（汗）
チョコレート
あっまー(嬉)
おおー！打ち消されるな！
打ち消せるぞこれ
最後、納豆
はい！というわけで、今からペヤング焼きそば
ここにあるの
あっちぃー
ここにあるペヤング焼きそば全部ぶちこんで
最強においしいペヤングを作っていこうと思いまぁすっ！
もうガンガンいきますからね、もう
混ぜれば美味しいの発想ですから
ぽいっ
チョコ
やああー！！
はい、というわけで、全部入ったんですが
ここからちゃんと混ぜないと
ちゃんと混ぜないと味が混ざんないんで
ここが1番重要だと思います
っしゃあー
はい！いっちょあがり！
めっちゃ入念に混ぜたんで、
ちゃんと混ざってると思われます
果たして、究極のペヤングはどのような味を奏でてくれるのでしょうか？
いただきます
（10種類のペヤングを混ぜ、）
（究極の美味を秘めた伝説の焼きそば）
（今まさに彼は伝説を口に頬張ったのです）
（そして）
（こう言いました）
はい、完食しましたー！